okay so big brother house for a month
what was that like for you crazy
like i honestly can't even believe i'm
sitting in front of you
like just seeing other people i thought
for some reason in some small way
that being on the real housewives of
atlanta for 11 seasons would have
prepared me for this
girl
[Laughter]
listen like
i
i'm still processed and i can't even
blame out of the house it is official
cynthia
you are the last celebrity evicted from
the big brother house i will say
i love i love me some cynthia bailey
hill but there's no way i would have
taken you to the finals if i was there
you would have beat everybody i know
there's no way i would have taken you to
the finals listen
first of all i
honestly went into that house thinking i
told mike my husband i was like i just
promise i won't be the first one to get
me kicked out
so when i made it to the final three i
was like wait what is happening i didn't
win
any games
any competitions and i was picked to be
in every last one of them
and i was like if can't win for losing
was a person it's me
and i wish i could say that my strategy
was to lose to not get a target on my
back but i actually wanted to win
something
i am blown away and the fact is you're
just so like you had a great social game
because you're just genuinely nice and
genuinely like you're kind of cool and
you kind of fit into every little corner
i clean more toilets let me tell you
something about celebrities they're not
clean people no they're not clean people
if you can see the toilets that i had to
clean oh cynthia i want to talk about
tonight why did you decide to vote for
todrick over misha okay
so
i voted for todrick
because after carson left i was alone in
the house lamar and todd had each other
miesha and todrick had each other so i
was kind of like a lone wolf and he kind
of like took me under his wing
uh i'm sure i'm gonna find out why now
when i watched the show
but at the time it felt like okay great
because i was kind of third willing it
and honestly
i shouldn't say this but after carson
left i didn't really even want to be in
the house anymore because i was like
well my ride or die is gone and
everyone's all like you know has their
like you know person that they've been
riding with and right you know when
you're actually in the house it feels
like your alliance is your world
congratulations misha
you are the winner
of celebrity big brother so what is your
reaction to misha winning over todrick
well
i
felt like it could go either way i
figured they would make it to the final
two
you know they were they were a dynamic
duo
however um you know misha won hoh long
more than anyone i mean it was like
basically everyone else that one in that
room was just written it from her
because it was her room right so she had
a lot of blood on her hands too and her
and todrick were so tight and they made
every decision together
like
they were the same person so i was
surprised i was so confused
when
i
got on when i went on stage to meet my
stone-faced cast who has seen the show
and i haven't seen anything i was like
wait what is going on so when everyone
started voting it was all like misha and
i was like uh
it was icy on that stage
what like what is going on those folks
got a good lesson in housewife shade on
the way out because there were jabs
being thrown at what left and right yes
during the voting i was when i was
watching i was like oh
oh no everybody was like big mad and i
was sitting next to todd and he was like
oh he was rolling his eyes
he was doing a lot
not happy i was like what in the world
like i cannot wait to get home well
first i just want to see my husband and
my kids but
i got i was going to decompress tonight
i was like please have a massage ready
for me but i think i got to watch your
show
because you know when when todd voted he
said he said everything was great until
he saw the live feeds and winning is
doing it in a good way and not talking
bad about people that are already gone
do you think that your vote might have
changed if you had like them had been
able to see
the show 100 yeah 100 okay if what i'm
hearing is true
100 i would not have been able to vote
when carson left the house he
immediately apologized to shayna for
what went down for being wrong and how
he handled that situation even
apologized to her again tonight i wanted
to apologize to shayna because as you
said in the interview i should have
trusted actions and not somebody's words
and i'm sorry for that and i know it
made for an uncomfortable time for you
in the house and i deeply regret that do
you have anything to say to shane or
were you able to say anything to her i
have not been able to talk to her yet
and again i haven't watched for myself
but i've been doing interviews so it
sounds like you know
you know i owe her an apology you know
personal and public you know i really
hope that i can make it right you know
for me i was just doing whatever what i
thought was right for my reality at that
time in the house which was protecting
my alliance and you know carson was my
right right or die and he was so good to
shana and i so anyone coming for carson
in any way or anyone's saying i was like
no that's carson listen you made it to
the final three so what what was most
like i guess maybe confusing what was
the most confusing part of big brother
for you
um i didn't really understand the rules
i think if there was a book of things to
don't do
on big brother i could write that book
like even like i was i went in
everything i said i was gonna do
like it was like i was like okay first
of all when i go in i'm not gonna join
an alliance so as soon as i got in
carson was the first person yeah we went
together i was like oh shoot i'm an
alliance already all right and then i
didn't know we were supposed to keep the
alliance a secret do you have other
alliances already i
i kind of fell into one right away with
carson and
gina
dodrick
like i didn't know it was a super so
when other people would come up to
recruit me i'd be like oh i'm in an
alliance i'm with carson i'm with shayna
and i'm with todrick we call ourselves
the more nation
and everyone's looking at me like you're
not supposed to tell them and i'm like
i was proud that i even got picked to be
in an alliance i was a disaster
it was only by the grace of god and it
was my potato salad and me cleaning
those doors
that got my butt to uh being you know oh
the last three but what do you think is
tougher celebrity big brother or the
real housewives ultimate girls trip
celebrity big brother yes definitely i
had a tough time in the end ultimate
girl you could have you could get uh
celebrity big brother it takes a special
group of people to do that show honestly
and i don't care how much tv time you've
had how much reality how many reality
shows you've done
you